[Music]
welcome everyone to this conversation on
AI AR VR maybe some other twetter
abbreviations who knows where it will go
but it's an exploration of these ideas
with jarn lanir let me just give a quick
introduction I'm sure most people in the
audience are quite familiar with who he
is but he is the prime unifying
scientist at Microsoft where he helps
lead the company's development and
implementation of artificial
intelligence systems he's a leading
computer scientist who's done pioneering
work in the field of virtual real ity a
bestselling author who has written
extensively about technology and its
impact on society he's a musician with a
deep interest in unique and historical
musical instruments and a composer of
new classical music in 2018 he was named
one of the 25 most influential people in
the previous 25 years of Tech History by
Wired Magazine which is pretty good he's
also been named one of the 100 most
influential people in the world by Time
Magazine and one of the top 100 public
intellectuals in the world World by
foreign policy magazines so those are
quite a range of credentials so welcome
jiren it's so nice to see you hey Brian
good to see you how's everything going
oh it's it's great it's great good you
know I was just thinking in preparation
for this conversation about the first
time we met I don't know if you remember
it's about 25 years ago I came to your
apartment in Manhattan which was very
similar to what I'm seeing in the
background in your shot right now chalk
full of instruments that's right yeah
you know I remember delicately walking
around because there was barely any
floor space that wasn't covered by an
instrument yeah I've since learned to
put them more up on the walls uh having
a child taught me the value of having
floor space so yeah no doubt no doubt
and so I this won't be the focus of our
conversation per se but where did that
fascination with musical instrument come
from I think it came from my mother uh
what happened was uh she was a holocaust
Survivor who kept me very close and
before she was taken by the Nazis at age
13 she'd been a prodigy performer in
Vienna and she really treasured uh
teaching me to play the piano and uh
some other instruments and then she died
when I was quite young in a car
accident um
and somehow music became my continuing
connection to her and in particular this
experience of learning a new instrument
and so I just keep on learning new ones
and all I can say is I think it's still
cheaper than heroin and as far as like
ridiculous obsessions go I hope it's one
of one of the less damaging ones but it
does get a bit extreme but anyway that's
who I am and I I won't pretend to be
otherwise I'm an instrument fanatic
that's how it go that is a that's a
remarkable story um and and so do you
have one instrument in particular that
you consider your instrument or is it
really you just continue to expand the
repertoire well not really I mean um the
piano a little I suppose which is this
black thing covered right there but
um I it always varies which one I'm
playing more than others and uh I've
been burning through all kinds of
instruments from different cultures now
for decades
um who can make sense of it yeah you
know we're gonna talk signs of course
but I also recall that you and I were
once both part of a music festival
together in California Philip GL was
having a a music festival and I was
collaborating with him on right and you
were collaborating with him too uh yeah
Philip and I did a lot together he
produced some of my records way back in
the 90s when we
were we were we Lads I guess and um we
were still playing at least once a year
together until recently and uh you know
um he's getting up there in years and I
don't I don't know what the future holds
but I really love the guy yeah no he's
quite wonderful I mean our my
collaboration with him you know and
World science fesal collaboration with
him was really a highlight of Performing
Arts things that we've done you know it
also turns out and I suspect you're not
aware of this that our lives intersected
even before that at least in principle
because when I was at IBM this is way
back in the 1980s I work for a guy named
John cooch I don't know if you know that
name but he introduced me to Marvin
Minsky and Ed fredkin at MIT and my
understanding is that those
guys especially Marvin had a profound
influence on you right yeah Marvin was
um with whom I absolutely disagree about
everything Marvin was a uh astonishingly
generous mentor to me uh he was my boss
I was hired as a young researcher at MIT
when I was I think still a teenager and
really yeah like way back um and uh I
uh I love Marvin and I I really do
disagree with him very profoundly about
almost everything but it's all right and
Ed fredin of course was a buddy but not
we never really work together
um but Marvin yeah very important person
in my life and so so Marvin I guess
together with John McCarthy maybe others
that you could fill me in on I don't
know the history that well but that this
is really where artificial intelligence
began right ah yes well the history I
there's some history I have a high
degree of confidence in being able to
relate to you because I was there but
some of this is from before my time so I
have to re re rely on what people tell
me and they tell me different things so
I have to do my best to to infer um it's
one of those things like virtuality
where if you want to find antecedence
going way back in history you can find
it with the ancient Greeks or whatever
but right I think a nice starting place
is AA love La the first programmer and
aah um thought about it and decided AI
wasn't a good way of thinking and it's
just the human programmer we should we
should concentrate on as the entity um
and then about the human the human
programmer the human programmer right
that was A's where she where she landed
on it and then um probably the next
major thinker I think would be em
Forster uh the the the famous novelist
who wrote a vision of what the future
internet and computer science might be
like in I think it was 1907 I might have
that slightly wrong but something like
that first decade of the 20th century um
which is sort of an astonishing Act of
premonition I mean it's almost
Supernatural and makes me question
whether time is what it seems to be
because it seems impossible that he
could have written it and he also had a
very strong was that like a white paper
or because I'm not a Nolla is what we
usually call it it's a somewhere in
length between a short story and a novel
and it's a it's the Prototype dystopian
science fiction novel um
1984 and Brave New World and the Matrix
movies and so many others are obviously
following the plan laid out by the
machine stops great they they all have a
similarity in the characters and the
overall
themes and uh uh that one was a deeply
humanist work that was critical of the
idea of of of putting too much stock in
the machine as a center or as an entity
um where we really see the tables turn
is with Alan
Turing um oh and I should mention van
ofar Bush who who uh thought about uh
computers and networks and algorithms as
a way to help people but it was still
person Centric now Turing turns it
around and proposes well maybe we should
think of these things as entities but
what I always ask people to do is think
about the context in which Turing did
that uh here's a guy who help helped win
World War II who was declared one of the
most important combatants against the
Nazis he was a savior of all those who
didn't want to be killed because of
their arbitrary identity that they
couldn't do anything about right and yet
here he was after the war condemned
precisely because of his identity that
he couldn't do anything about because
being gay was illegal yeah and he was
forced into a bizarre quack medical
treatment where he was getting female
hormones and to understand why somebody
would try to cure gayness with female
hormones it sounds so
Twisted but the metaphors at that time
were pre-computer ones it was all about
the steam engine and the idea was
equalizing pressure so maybe if you the
opposite hormone will equalize the
pressure and I don't I don't know you
know what yeah trying to make sense of
something stupid only can go so far but
anyway he was starting to develop
secondary uh female secondary sexual
characteristics he didn't want uh so far
as we can tell he committed suicide in
quite a poetic manner by uh eating a
cyanide laced Apple in front of the
first computer right so sort of an anti-
eve or something like that um the Turing
test his famous idea was written down
just in this last phase of his life
before his death and he proposes
well really the only judge of whether
their person's a person is another
person and if that person can't really
give you a rational basis for saying
this one's a person that one isn't then
call them all people or call them all
nonp people but don't make the choice
and I think there was something coming
out of a
deeply absurdest dysphoric place because
that's where his life was and I think we
have to understand it almost as a
critique of what was happening to him
rather than as an idea to take it face
value right that's my don't take on it
um you could say I don't have any right
to interpret Turing to that degree but
then who does really you know yeah sure
sure all right so then after
touring um the next major figure flips
it again and this is where we get to
Norbert weiner right so Norbert
weiner uh says you know so there there's
a standard model of what a computer is
which tring developed um along with the
astonishing uh mathematician physicist
John V noyman who's almost like a person
of surreal talents who's very hard to
even
Creed is real but there there he is so
anyway uh the Turing Von noyman
machine is a an abstract device that
receives an input uh a strip of of
values processes and then either gets
stuck forever or comes to an end and
gives you an answer now uh Norbert
weiner looked at this and said
mathematically this is very general this
is great but it doesn't help us
understand the real world where we see
or organisms and we see uh complex
systems interacting the weather and the
oceans and all these things so let's
reconceive this in a different way which
I'm going to call the cybernetic way
that was his
term uh cyber comes from the ancient
Greek for navigating and he said instead
of thinking of a system that's just
logic gates let's think of it as a
tangled network of thermometers we're
going to say we have measurement and
feedback networks and the thing is
always on it's always is connected so
when as the environment around it
changes what it gives back to the
environment changes now strictly from a
computability point of view they're
equivalent but in terms of the way you
can position them in their environment
they're different um and
weiner in terms of so that that's part
of his technical Legacy and and at the
time he was quite a celebrity scientist
he's less well known now but in um he
lipped the argument back away from tring
he wrote for instance a book called the
human use of human beings and it ends
with this crazy thought experiment which
is what if you could give every person
in the world a little radio connected
device that would give them some kind of
experience based on what happens in some
Central Computer somewhere and that
Central Computer was observing how they
behaved and changing what signal they
got in a feedback loop to to put them in
a behaviorist kind of experiment like
have Skinner or or pavlof did with their
animals is that imaginable turning the
whole human world into a big cybernetic
system and he says this is only a
thought experiment as a scientist I want
to tell you this is not possible yeah
and of course we did it we are there his
point is that if you start to think of
people in computers as being equivalent
you'll start to treat people like
computers and you can destroy society
and destroy everything um and then okay
now here what I've heard from a few
people and I absolutely am in no
position to judge whether this is true
is that in person vener was kind of
arrogant or difficult I don't know but
anyway apparently he rubbed a lot of
people the wrong way and part of what
happened with the early artificial
intelligence movement was a bunch of
people who were just uncomfortable or
pissed off with them or something so
McCarthy and Minsky and a bunch of
others had a a famous meeting in 58 I
believe in Dartmouth where they coined
the term artificial intelligence which
was initially designed as an alternate
term to cybernetic yeah yeah yeah right
I've heard and then they P they try to
pull it back to the other side and there
we are so that that's the briefest
history as I understand it no it's a
great history and and of course for for
most of us it's been an abstract idea
obviously I'm not in the field and for
you know my entire professional life
everybody who until recently everybody
who spoke about artificial intelligence
it was always something that might
happen and then sort of of November of
2022 takes place and all of a sudden it
feels like it's no longer as abstract as
it once was with chat gbt and and so on
do you consider in the science of the
development of the subject is chat GPT a
vital moment or is it a passing moment
oh yeah you know um I like it and look
it's it's some kind of
weird irony of faith that I'd end up in
the middle of this thing that I'd always
been sort of cynical about that it just
happened that way nobody planned it yeah
see the way I interpret it is there's no
AI there there's no entity I'm still
with with aah and with Norbert Weiner
and so on uh in that um and I I could
continue the history beyond that it's
always been bouncing back and forth Doug
engelbart after Minsky pushed it back in
the other direction who you know uh and
and many other important figures there's
a whole long game of tennis going on
between the camps here but um from my
perspective the right way to think about
the large models like chat PT uh is as a
collaboration between people you take in
what a bunch of people have done right
and you combine it in a new way which uh
is very good at finding
correlations and then what comes out is
a collaboration of those people that is
different and in many ways uh more
useful than previous collaborations but
there's still no entity there there's no
AI there's just the people uh you know
collaborating in this new way and when I
think about it that way I find it much
easier to come up with useful
applications that'll really help I find
it much easier to think about its role
in society and just in general it makes
more sense say it's just like a giant
mashup from the internet basically you
know all text that's out there and just
combine it and recombine it in New Way
some of it's from the internet some of
it's from other sources you know like uh
without going into details we've tried
our best to bring in the highest quality
sources that might not actually be
online to try to give it um to bring
collaborators in who are good at
particular technical or informational
things that might be AB to people but at
any rate it still is a collaboration of
human individuals at the end of the day
and uh I think it's a good one I find it
helpful I find it useful I don't think
there's an entity there but of course I
mean perceiving an entity is a matter of
faith if you want to believe your plant
is talking to you you can you know like
I'm not going to go and judge you but
sure this is similar to that like it's
yeah POS I totally I totally agree with
you on that Jaren I mean you know theory
of mind or the intentional stance
whatever word you know an evolutionist
psychologist or otherwise might use
benefited the species it was better to
imagine that there were entities out
there even if perhaps they weren't
because if they were there they could
eat you and better to anticipate their
presence than to overlook them by not
assigning them agency so I totally I
totally get that but I too do not do not
see an entity in there but I'm wondering
and I don't mean to put you on the spot
at all but the notion of what's in there
is such an opaque one do you have a
working way of describing what happens
inside of a large language
model okay um I believe I can help with
this I haven't quite yet but just give
me a little more time um I have uh a
Layman's explanation of how our large
models work uh coming out soon in a a
major journal that I think people might
find useful and I've been play testing a
way of talking about that uh which I can
I can tell you about if you want yeah I
would love to if you were willing but
the other thing is uh well okay I'll do
it why don't I give the briefest version
of how how this stuff works but then I
also want to describe to you an
additional layer I think we can add to
it to make its role in society and the
role of people in it much clearer yeah
okay so uh how it
works let us start very simply with the
thing all of us were obsessed with 10 or
12 years ago which is can you get a
program to tell a cat from a dog and
so you can do statistical measurement of
a frame and see if it's more blue or
more red that's easy it doesn't give it
give you whether it's a cat or dog
yeah you can uh find uh fiducial points
that are maybe points where lines
intersect and things change and that
might give you an outline of a face but
that still doesn't help you because
they're similar they have snouts and fur
and everything yeah and I was doing that
kind of stuff I in fact God I sold a
company to Google with some some friends
a quarter century ago uh that that did
this fiducial point tracking um and you
can get pretty far but it doesn't help
you how is how the computer knows your
face to log you in it's still it has its
role but it doesn't tell a cat from a
dog uh so what does work is what we call
Deep learning and what that means is you
have a grid of kind of really simplistic
statistical measures along the ones
we've just talked about and then there's
another grid looking at that one and
another one looking at that one and it
turns into a sort of a highrise and then
even that doesn't do it but then you
have to train it you give it known cats
and known dogs and whenever the
particular weights which means how much
you value the output of a particular
grid on one of on each of these many
stories it's divided into grid grids
every time it seems to work you make
those settings more valuable when it's
less valuable you get rid of it yeah
gradually you train it this is called
gradient descent and I'm oversimplifying
it it um but it's really interesting
because the thing about gradient descent
is it's antiviral meaning like online
the way we choose things as we say well
if this thing's popular it'll get even
more popular and then more popular more
popular and then the problem with that
is that then you only have these viral
things which are often the worst stupid
things but to train a network you have
to look at the overall combination so
you're constantly batting down virality
that's what makes gradient descent work
it's kind of marvelous like we don't
have the wisdom to do that with our
society but we have to do it we're
forced to do it in the training so then
you end up at the top layer gives you
cat versus dog as an output okay so
that's only cats and dogs the way you do
it for everything everything everything
is you look at the whole damn internet
and you assume adjacency is important
you say if one word tends to follow
another word or tends to be close to it
maybe that means something yeah if some
words are close to some image maybe
they're descriptive of the image not
absolutely certainly but they'll tend to
be
and then instead of knowing in advance
that you have tagged cats and dogs you
use adjacency to tag the whole internet
approximately train the whole thing and
it takes us astonishing computational
resources and like a year to do one of
these Cycles so every time you see GPT
turning like from three to four it's one
of these giant yeah and now what you
have is this huge sort of uh you can you
can think of it as a a virtual Forest of
these towers that are like one I just
described except they're not like
delineated they're all sort of virtually
there and they're all mhed up but here's
the thing the magic that comes is you
can call on more than one of them at a
time to sort of blend the you can blend
them so um there have been a number of
critiques like from timu and from uh
many others saying well it's stochastic
parrots you know it's just regurgitating
and that's true I mean that's accurate
but the magic is the combination so if
you say I want a picture
of um a Geral uh writing
um uh riding a stock car on the moon or
some crazy thing and I want it in the
style of Monae it'll it'll start with
just random pixels put them through that
combination of these trees and then if
it gets a little closer to satisfying
all of them all of them then it'll keep
the result and if not it'll throw it
away then it just keeps on cycling
through until it gets closer and closer
to s to addressing all of them at once
and then you have this image come out
that looks like that which is kind of
crazy and great and then you can say
write me uh write me a caption for this
picture that sounds like a a pirat edit
and then it'll do the same thing using
adjacency in the text and it'll do
it I think that's great I think that's
that has a lot of utility yeah I'm I'm
happy it's there but but here's um what
I would suggest as an image to get a
feeling for its limits are
if you imagine one of these uh prompts
that combines access to different uh
Towers if you like if you can accept
this sort of confusing set of metaphors
perhaps um you have uh you have gerbal
stock car was it Mars Monae whatever
okay so you have the set of things in
between them there was never a tower to
recognize the combination and it sort of
constructs a virtual tower for the
combination in order to be the feedback
to generate this new image in generative
AI right the key issue to understand is
that I can fill in the gaps but it
typically only randomly will go a little
bit above it doesn't go higher than the
original Towers right so it's a
collaboration but not arbitrary
constructive intelligence now when I say
that people will say well how do you
know that people do
more that's the wrong question I'm not
talking about people I'm trying to say
let's understand what these models can
do and this is a good approximate
intuitive way of understanding what
they're good at and what they're not
good at but even if it's yeah go ahead
but even if it's the the wrong question
I can't help but ask for your intuition
on the relationship between what you
just described really wonderfully well
you know in in layman's language what's
going on which in essence is these
systems wind up having the capacity to
give output based on recognizing like
patterns of patterns of patterns of
patterns as it goes up the tower
how is that related if at all to what we
human beings do because our intelligence
is certainly in part about finding
patterns and patterns and patterns and
from that being able to extrapolate to
something that perhaps wasn't IM
initially there as part of the data set
yeah I
mean I think the cor the best ansers
that we don't
know at present because we have the this
working thing the large language models
it's very natural for people to look for
something similar to that in the way
that natural biological neurons tend to
organize themselves in layers which
might be a little reminiscent there are
some important differences uh natural
biological brains can learn things with
far fewer examples yeah of course and
every single day and I'm not
exaggerating every single day there's a
new paper published in some AI Journal
somewhere that says we've cracked it we
have a program that can now learn in as
few number of examples as a person it
never turns out to quite be true it just
every single day every single day
there's somebody has new unified theory
uh that's a slight dig at your
profession but never mind that and then
uh ours they don't come out every single
day in our field but have you looked at
the archive I mean okay not every day
not every day don't do it you're you're
that's a wise decision but anyway um the
thing is the thing is uh there is that
difference and also we don't have to get
it to work in in our computer programs
this issue of having the Deep neural
network which means a lot of these
layers is really important uh and we
don't seem biological systems don't seem
to have that requirement and then the
other thing is that the training
methodology appears to be different
rather than a sort of the global
gradient uh descent thing it it's a
different sort of mechanism so there
there are there different is there how
deep those differences are is really not
well understood I'm all for doing the
research it you know we had a
conversation with Yan Lon um and his I'm
wondering what you think about it and
obviously I'm sure you know far better
than I do what his perspective is but
the point that was of interest to me was
he was emphasizing that what these large
language models lack compared to this
thing inside of our heads is this
ability to reason you know ability to
have a model built up of the world into
which you put the data and rather than
just throw all the data in there and try
to find patterns try to put the data
within a template within a rubric that
reflects how the world really works do
you think that that is for instance the
natural next step for where the
technology will go well
um so this reflects a bit of history in
the community so uh from the time that
Marvin and his cohorts started to have a
Triumph against the cyberneticists and
whatnot They promoted a style of AI
That's often called symbolic AI where
it's all model and it's in the early
days when I was a kid it was described
using uh formal logic you know the idea
is that we're gonna really we're gonna
Pretend We're russl and Whitehead and
we're gonna like just describe the world
from these fundamental things right so
then the type of AI that started to work
more uh this Century let's say in the
last 10 years is different and it's this
large model very statistical thing and
so it's very natural that a lot of
people are saying can we combine these
and a great deal of effort goes into
that and you'll see um once again
without exaggeration every day there'll
be in your report of some kind of a
combination of a statistical and a and a
logical uh so-called AI they're very
different so I don't know why they're
both called AI but but they are um and
some of them have been to good effect uh
for instance you can uh train a model on
a bunch of examples that are coming from
a a logic based system and this has been
used for instance to create an AI to
solve U geometry problems famously
announced by Google recently and um so
there there I think there are all kinds
of cases where the combination works so
far we don't really have a way of
generalizing that approach it tends to
be nichy but it seems worthwhile to
pursue it we certainly are yeah and and
so when
you experience the current state of
affairs in a field that you know you're
there right at the beginning of of
thinking about this kind of stuff or at
least you know at the in the modern way
of thinking about this kind of stuff
were you did you have a wow moment in in
in playing with any of these systems and
saying I just never thought put enough
data in and follow this procedure of you
know fixing the weights through this
descent mechanism that we would be able
to do what we do or is it like yeah uh
it's cool but I me I I feel a bit sad
saying this like it's a little pathetic
but I never really got to have the wow
moment I did for virtual reality stuff
and I still do but for AI you know like
um the the generative prompt thing where
you combine you combine things and have
constraints uh transform random pixels
into something that looks like yeah I
was looking through wild stuff we had
proposed that and talked all about how
could work as early as the 80s in the
mid 80s right we were talking about that
process and in a sense it hasn't been
surprising and I sort of wish it would
be because everybody likes that
sensation you know uh but uh whether or
not it's surprising to me I don't think
it's particularly important to anybody
uh but no I think for me I was denied
that sense of surprise about it and what
about what about some of the fear that
certainly some of your colleagues and
certainly you know many commentators
around the world describing how you know
this could be the beginning of of the
end does any of that have a grip on you
or do you think it's all just
fearmongering
and I mean
um I have to really
emphasize that it's all about people
it's all about humans and so the right
question is is to ask could humans use
this this stuff in such a way to bring
about a species threatening Calamity
yeah and I think the clear answer is yes
um now I should say that I think that's
also true of other Technologies and has
been true for a while I mean the truth
is that the better we get with
Technologies the more responsible we
have to be the less we are beholden to
fate and the more we take charge and the
natural corela to that is the more power
we have to destroy ourselves and there
there's no way out of that I mean the
power
um the power to support a large
population means the power to transform
the Earth which means the power to
transform the climate which means the
responsibility to take charge of the
climate when we didn't before and
there's there's no way out of that chain
that leads to Greater responsibility so
um I think the particular way the thing
is framed based on the movies people
grew up with like the Matrix or the
Terminator movies with Skynet is not
helpful generally because it tends to
frame it as there's this other entity
that will arise and that thing will be
the threat it'll take over and
ultimately the way to fix this is to
frame it again and again as human
responsibility the more we hypothesize
that we're creating aliens who will come
and invade the less we're taking
responsibility for our own stuff yeah
that makes a lot of sense to me but even
framed in that
way you know it feels like it's pretty
hard but obviously we know it's not at
all impossible for you know
non-governmental individual actors to
get a hold of a nuclear weapon not
impossible by any means but it's it's
kind of hard you know if someone
challenged me to build a nuclear weapon
I kind of know how they work on the
inside but I'm not good with my hands
I'd have difficulty putting one together
you know but but when it comes to these
systems it feels like they're they're
more at our fingertips and that's what I
think you know but but but all right so
look let me let me describe the thing
that I think we should do that would
help with all of this that I didn't get
to yet so this is called dignity so the
idea is when you're training the big
model if you think of it as a sort of a
forest of towers using the metaphor it
just gave you yeah let us imagine that
you can leave breadcrumb
in that forest and you can say this
particular
Source document from this individual
person was disproportionately
important to this particular output that
we got from the
system so when I say I want an image of
a Geral well which Geral well I can
actually say hey it's mostly this
particular Geral who comes from a Geral
breeder in New South Wales or I don't
know whatever you know you can actually
lose the anonymity and tie it to
specific soures now why is that
important I'll tell you a few reasons
let us suppose uh you want to put
guardrails on these things that they're
not used terribly and believe me we do
and we put great and I should make I'm
not speaking for Microsoft here I'm I'm
sure there are plenty of individuals at
Microsoft who wouldn't accept everything
I say so this is just me that's an
arrangement I have with them but at any
rate what I can say is that we meaning
Microsoft open Ai and the broader
community that does this at at a high
level seriously work on um guard rails
to keep it from being terrible and and
that's the reason why nothing Terrible's
happened so far in the first year of
this stuff or year and a half whatever
it's been and uh the uh that has
involved so you can think of this as a
triptic like a like the herous b triptic
or something you have the input data you
have the outputs and then there's this
middle which is Hell which is this weird
thing that's understand okay so right
now because the parts that are
intelligible are the input and the
output we have guard rails on those two
parts so input means trying to avoid
destructive training so we try not to
train on you know things to kill people
or whatever but of course it's very hard
to do
because you can the system will infer
that by combining things and then on the
output we try to catch things so here's
a very hypothetical example let's say
we're having one of these conferences
where we have uh kids pretending to be
bad actors who try to Ed the system to
show us where we're not doing a good as
good a job and there's there's been a
lot of that and so somebody says I want
a cake recipe and then sorry what I
didn't hear a cake recipe like a a
wedding cake but I want the cake and
they find some language I don't even
know what it would be they want the cake
to be plans to make a bomb maybe maybe
this uh atomic bomb that that uh even so
you could understand how to do it all
right so this this cake is going to come
out with this bomb plan in it and so by
doing that it evades guard rails both on
coming in and coming out but the thing
is if you
trace what source content was needed to
make that output right it'll Trace back
to something about how to make a bomb
inevitably and so suddenly you can
illuminate where the dangers are and
catch them in a way that that's very
hard to do if you're just trying to
characterize inputs and outputs and how
they might be combined in unforeseen
ways but you consider that is is that is
that a realist I guess the two things
that come to mind to me on that art One
technical are the levels of influence on
an output sufficiently distinct that you
can really point to one and say yeah
that is that how it really happens this
is still basic research in progress and
so it's possible that everything I'm
saying will not work out okay however um
there indications that it
can and
um I'm my main research partner are not
in the business world they're at
universities I'm trying to do it in such
a way that whatever we do is not in any
particular camp like us versus the
Google Camp or whatever uh but anyway um
the uh the question is all right first
of all how do you characterize what
deserves a breadcrumb and it's not a
one-dimensional thing it's not just
influence it's influence plus Fung
abilities it's at least two dimensions
and it's it's kind of like you can think
of it as representing a field that's
going through uh the training process
and uh the geometry of the field isn't
something we totally know yet and then
the next question is how can we
characterize that field so that we get a
really strong pero principle in the
results so we can say that for this
particular output they'll tend to be
fewer than a dozen top inputs that
matter even though in an in a broader
sense everything yeah so the question is
what does the Pito Peak look like and so
far based on a few examples it looks
like they'll be a nice healthy poo Peak
almost all the time uh there's still a
lot of math to
do it's uh some of it's actually
challenging I'm sorry to report so yeah
I mean I mean that that that sounds like
a promising
Direction but I guess the other thing
that comes to mind is what if it is in
the mashup phase that the
more difficult or dangerous or well the
the thing is it still has to trace back
certain kinds of content still has to
trace back and this has to
do with the limited ability so that's
why I'm saying the system can fill in
the blanks between trees but not go
above them yeah now um the
counterargument to that is if you
combine it with the logical type of
system or the formal system we're
talking about maybe that thing can climb
above but you know what um thus
far um I'm not too concerned about that
because the question isn't how well the
system can perform but how well it can
perform losing any Providence that about
what allowed it to perform that way and
and that's a different question and
there I'm feeling pretty confident that
there's a solution space right now you
also Advocate I gather that this
breadcrumb approach might be a way of
sharing the Bounty at some point of
actually those sources so just tell us a
bit about you're thinking on well I mean
a popular idea in Silicon Valley is or
you know the AI world or whatever is um
that we'll put a lot of people out of
work but then we'll have this this uh
Universal basic income and I I don't
trust that solution and there's a bunch
of reasons I don't one is that anytime
there's sort of a single paay for a
society it becomes really tempting for
takeover by the worst actors yeah and
the way I sometimes put this is you
might start with Bolsheviks but then you
get
stalinists because there's this thing
that's really tempting and and creeps
are going to want it you know yeah um
and there's a human nature element that
is unavoidable in this well I think if
if there were seop pods doing it the
game theory would be the same I just
think that's true I think it's a it's
just a perverse incentive and it's
really problematic uh and furthermore
um the the systemic challenges of
keeping something like even if has only
the best people doing it the politics of
it and the stability of it are probably
going to be really unpleasant uh and um
uh most of the science fiction that's
tried to foresee a world like this where
people aren't needed starting with the
machine stops but then you can see a
very nice example of it in The Matrix
movies subdue and contain humans in some
way because this idea is that people
would become like horrible without being
totally controlled and contained they
have to be in little pods or cells or
something and that intuition which has
been repeated for well over a century in
science fiction I believe is correct so
I think there's a better way which is if
you can trace who added the value to the
AI system with their examples pay
royalties pay them dividends give get
them into a professional Society where
they they share some kind of a fee for
licensing or something like why do we
have to end the idea of an economy just
because we have this new tool that's
better there's actually no reason why we
can't continue the economy idea into
this new era and I think that would be a
healthier more distributed more
dignified way to do it and do you feel
confident that if that approach could be
realized that you wouldn't run into
problems of the sort that there are many
like let's just talk about your gerbal
example there are so many places where
there so many places where you can
imagine the primary gerbal image coming
from and the the output would still be
really good regardless of which of them
gets used and yet if one is primary that
individual who I don't know took that
photograph or drew that picture will get
that Bounty everybody else won't well
you now how I was saying in the process
of gradient descent that we use to train
yeah a neural network we have to
actively fight against virality in order
to not have the system spin out of
control uh so one way to put this is we
have to avoid attractor I don't know I I
don't know how technical your audience
yeah you can go a little bit further
yeah sure but at any rate the idea is
that you you're interested in this
subtle combination rather than letting
any one component of the training uh
Dynamic dominate right and so what we
have to do is recognize that what works
inside also works outside and do the
same thing in all of our society level
systems we have to avoid virality in the
way the stuff is calculated uh I wish we
were doing it online I think we'd have a
much healthier and happier world right
now yeah I mean again you've been very
vocal along that direction too and
things I've read I I I largely agree
with where you know you talk about the
virality you talk about the pernicious
nature of of social media which I don't
want to put words in mouth let you say
it yourself but this idea that a system
has as its goal to addict you and pull
you in and trains Itself by virtue of
what works on you this is you know
exactly the antithesis of a system would
allow you know freedom to Reign so so
how does AI play into this because when
the combination seems you know again
it's human actors but it seems
terrifying well you know the funding for
the AI World from the end of the 90s
until recently was all for algorithms to
help addict people more yeah and um they
were uh what I'm hoping and a hope is
different than an actuality I've
discovered much to my suin but what my
hope is is that the Advent of AI will
start to force some of the companies
that rely on addiction to change their
business model uh so um for instance are
my good friends and colleagues at Google
might find that just having a
conversational AI answer somebody's
question is more efficient for that
person than a bunch of links to follow
right um I find this all the time if I'm
trying to find some really obscure
detailed answer from uh owner's manuals
for some equipment about how to get the
things to connect together and there's
different versions and different you
know whatever um I can use the
correlations in our lji model to just
get the answer instead of searching and
searching and going through in fact some
I you know it's better it's just better
sure so if you can do
that you have if if your model is
so-called advertising which I don't like
I think it it it um if it's possible it
denigrates advertising as a business
it's something different it's paid
influence and channeling and
amplification it's something darker than
advertising has been and advertising was
never entirely on this side of the
Angels but this is worse anyway yeah if
you have like here's here's my really
useful output from the language model
from the large language model Ai and now
here's 20 links you can follow if you
want nobody's gonna follow those those
links you know so
they're going to be forced to some kind
of different model either people are
going to pay to use the AI or something
or the AI will be corrupted and will
start to tell the people well before you
fix your water heater you really need to
do something about your breath and
here's our
new whatever okay something H and I I I
think at the end of that system of
things Google's forced into a different
business model that does less damage to
society I hope I hope yeah yeah yeah
totally so just to Circle back for a
second by I'm not speaking as Microsoft
I know I totally hear you I just also
just to I've sold a company to Google
their buddies I'm not I'm saying this
with affection and camaraderie not I I
don't mean to just dump on them really
no that's that's totally how I'm taking
it I trust our audience will as well but
I just want to Circle back you know we
started talking you know about all the
instruments behind you and and your deep
connection to music have you used any of
these AI I'm sure you have to explore
composition and I mean do you find there
there's utility there or do you find
there's creativity
there I for me no for me no and the
reason why is I'm actually going totally
in the opposite direction to me musical
instruments are the best user interfaces
that have ever been invented in some
ways if if what you think a technology
is for
is to help a
person affect the world with ever
greater Acuity than musical instruments
are the most Advanced Technologies that
have ever existed and so what I'm trying
to do is make computers more like them
not the other direction seems absurd to
me I just want to make sure I understand
I think I do I mean you know obviously
we've all had those Transcendent moments
where you're experiencing some
spectacular performance I mean is that
the kind of influence in the world that
that you're making I think more about
the act of playing an instrument do you
play anything I don't remember you know
not well a little bit you know actually
I just started playing piano again so in
my Advanced age I'm trying to see if I
can't do it but yeah not really good
good my my warmest wishes to your
neurons thank you I appreciate that when
you play an instrument you you start to
get this connection where you're getting
a lot of intent and data out there and
it's not just a question of the volume
of data but it's it's the focus and the
Acuity you know it's it can be really
remarkable the control a violinist has
over the string and the bow is by some
measures close to Quantum limit on
occasion you know it's like it's this
very intense thing and so what I want is
for computers to become more like that I
want computers to be more expressive
machines that people can connect to with
their whole bodies with their whole
nervous systems with their whole
cognition with ever more subtlety and
ever more Acuity so to me the
instruments have so much more to teach
the computers in the other direction
that the idea of using the current
software we have which I it's very
important for us to not think too much
of ourselves like I I always think of
that you know in the late 19th century
people were say oh physics is done
there's nothing more to explore this
they're wrong you know like we shouldn't
think oh we have it computers are done
AI is done you know that's ridiculous
like um we should be humble and in
particular we shouldn't think that the
Technologies of past centuries that
aren't computers are somehow just
inferior and ready to be disposed of and
replaced in some ways they might be
superior yeah they might have a lot to
teach us so the other direction to me
just seems so much more important is so
much has so much more potential and
interest like it's like it would just
seem nutty to me to you know I I I like
I'm not for people if somebody I'm not
judging anyone else if someone else
finds it meaningful go but yeah totally
yeah but along those lines in terms of
the the the interface I mean again as we
said at the outset and I'm sure the
audience knows you're kind of the
originator of VR right I mean it kind of
begins with you and your company well
just to clarify the the very idea of of
putting up head trck 3D that goes to
Ivan southernland who also invented 3D
Graphics in the first place what I did
is I did the first social ones with
avatars I did the first commercial ones
I did the first ones that were head
supported and where there were sort of
goggles that look like what we currently
think of so and I made up the term
virality and blah blah blah you know I
did a lot of stuff so we should clarify
but sure in some sense perhaps yeah but
profound connection to it in any event
and you know just recently I don't know
week or two ago I mean Apple comes out
with you know its its version yeah have
you have I'm sure you've tried it
probably long before I yeah so I mean
there's a long history to that oh my god
um 40 years ago uh when the Mac was
shipped some of the key people from the
Mac including Andy herzfeld who wrote
the first Mac OS came over to help us
with with the first VR OS and to ship
the first VR system yeah and the first
commercial headset was called an iPhone
but spilled
eye and that's good uh there's I don't
know exactly what the story but I've
been told by a number of people that
that directly led to the iPhone with an
why because the original IDE the
original idea from jobs and others in
apple when it was a very small nice and
thing when the the Macintosh hadn't even
shipped yet uh was that someday Apple
would sell a headset and we all
estimated it at uh
2010 oh that that you you thought that
that's when back in 1982 or three or
something we estimated 2010 well it's
actually pretty good terrible not
terrible yeah so um uh but yeah so
there's always been a certain contingent
that continued with an apple that wanted
Apple to eventually get into headsets
and so um and we've known they've been
working on this specific thing for a
long time and um I I don't want to get
into the details but I I had some access
to earlier versions of it and whatnot
and uh um I'm glad they're doing it you
know I think it has a wayte to go but
I'm I'm happy it's there but you don't
seem particularly excited about am I
reading it wrong or I'm cursed I've seen
all you know like this is I I would
like I would sometimes I really do wish
I had a different past so I could be
more startled by some of these things
because you know I see people using VR
devices these days or I see them using
chat GPT and being so surprised and
typically delighted occasionally
horrified but um I I'm sort of jealous
of those who can enjoy that you know
surprise um but I'm wondering if about
that because every time for instance I
teach quantum mechanics or special
relativity it's as if I've never seen
this subject before I find it so amazing
that we were able to figure this stuff
out and how it works what it tells us
don't do you not have that I have that
for the underlying science I totally
have that um the the particular product
experiences are a little different um
this might
be oh I don't know let's say one of
these Fusion startup starts to work and
there's like a fusion energy source and
U there's a slight chance that you would
be a little less startled by it because
you would have read the paper you'd
understand it right yeah that's oh yeah
okay there it is they they describe the
process it makes sense here it is here's
what yeah I like that analogy you know
what I mean and so that doesn't mean
that you're any less interested in that
you don't find the underlying physics
delightful and I do very much I mean I
I'm still totally interested in the uh
the physiology the the eyes the
cognition um the optical challenge of
doing a proper Optical PA through is
still not really solved and really
really interesting and right on the edge
of what we understand about light and
and how to manipulate it with materials
it's great I still get great joy from it
no no I heard you once talk about a
virtual reality general
relativity yeah thing which I I've never
seen I've never
experienced what was that oh gosh if
been a zillion of them I use this as an
example of something about VR which is
um uh that it's really harder to
maintain apps in VR over the years than
it is in other formats so I first
encountered somebody doing a relativity
experiential teaching thing in VR around
1992 I don't remember it very well and I
believe they were from somewhere state
New York probably Cornell but I'm not
positive and I might have that s it's
just so long I just but at any rate you
would go in and you'd be in this thing
where things are warped and if you tried
to move your body it would kind of
distort and um there have been some some
that demonstrate special some that
generate General yeah they've been
around for but the thing is every single
one of them only lasted a year right
right because the technology on yeah
yeah so like let's say um I say this
with love the first generation Apple
headset has a rather narrow field of
view um Hollow was worse so I'm not
saying there any but they're trying to
do something a little harder than what
other people have done so they have this
thing as soon as you make it broader you
can't just use the same apps anymore
everything's going to have to be redone
because it's so fundamental sure and so
when somebody let's say somebody says
okay we're gonna do a great relativity
teacher thing for this apple headset a
year later you're going to have
graduated school they're going to be in
different things it's not going to get
maintained it'll all way no I hear you I
hear you because we made I mean it turns
out that we World science we you know we
work with Verizon and we made these
virtual R experiences one of which is
what's it like to move near the speed of
light we have okay great so you made is
it still use by anybody but the but the
people who we work with to develop the
underlying
programming constantly need funding to
keep the experience able to run on the
Next Generation this that or the other
thing it's like yeah I know exactly what
you mean um so the solution to that in
my opinion is generative AI because one
of the um best successes of generative
AI has been encoding right so we often
see you I've seen different measurements
but the lowest General Improvement in
productivity I've seen claimed from
somebody who's done a serious study is
40% better but then there are lot there
are many that's say no no no it's much
higher than that I I don't but the point
is it's non-trivial like programmers are
more efficient and one of the great
things and and one of the things I've
been I've been working with my research
interns on for the last few years and
it's been in Crazy successful is prompt
based virtual world creation that's
spontaneous while you're in it so you go
around I'd like a relativity simulator
and furthermore I have ADHD and I'm
color blind or whatever that's yeah sure
you know and um I'd like it I'd like it
to be this and that and it should just
come up like you shouldn't have to go
through this whole process of developers
you now I don't know Apple might not
like that because they like to be more
control so it might not be on their
ecosystem I don't know that'll be up to
them but the point is that that's the
way around this problem and and and I'm
kind of you just build it fresh every
time you need it as yeah you don't even
bother saving it because it's not it
becomes a a n it's just this thing you
ask for there it is and then you ask for
it again and it might come up or maybe
you can save it if you like a particular
this really does feel like the Hol de on
right I mean you know you go in there
and you just create a world with a few
prompts or something well sure and I
mean
uh um not but to find a point on it but
back in the day my my group and the
people who made The Star Trek were
talking and that's not that's not
entirely a coincidence at all ah there
was always kind kind of the vision so
yeah wow that that that's
amazing but do you see let's just take
VR as a case in point do you see VR as
going Beyond cool experiences and
actually shaping our understanding of
key ideas and issues and philosophical
conundra that we have tussled with
throughout the ages and now by virtue of
creating these worlds and experiencing
things differently we could shed new
light on these old problems well okay so
my experience of VR is that it shines a
two extremes one is Extreme utility
which is to and and there it's been a
great industrial technology for decades
it's been universally used to improve
designs of planes and Automobiles and
ships and spacecraft it's almost
Universal it's been used for surgical
procedure design and training and
real-time assist it's been used for City
Planning it's all the so all that stuff
and that's a whole separate ecosystem
that people don't even see it's
different and that is that is I mean I'm
less aware that like city planners have
have made use yeah it's uh I the city
the vehicle prototyping I would say is
Universal City Planning is very
widespread but not Universal yeah um and
uh yeah and and so there's an ecosystem
that supports those people um it's
rapidly in the hardware of it is rapidly
merging with the consumer devices as as
always happens however it has its own
world of software and distribution its
own culture its own people it's a whole
it's like another thing yeah and it's a
set of different niches uh people
designing uh chemicals both both uh both
uh uh drug uh for drugs and for all
sorts of other things for industrial
processes organic and not inorganic and
then um there's uh anyway so there's
that world and that world's great I love
that World um but then uh there's the
Other Extreme which is the crazy art
stuff and that you know it's very
subject to interpretation because what
happens is you might create a virtual
world experience that at least for me
seems to teach a very specific lesson
about philosophy and thought but for
somebody else it might teach a different
lesson you know like uh there's no way
to perceive without your pre-existing
philosophy coloring what you perceive
it's it's just not possible so for
me when when I'm in a virtual world and
I make everything really weird I you can
change your body into animal bodies
which is an amazing thing about
cognition and you can uh you can you can
change the perception of the flow of
time and many many other crazy things
but the more crazy it gets the more you
notice that this thing that there's this
thing in the middle which I call the
little nub sometimes it's like your
Consciousness is there so it's a
Consciousness noticing machine and I'm
an Unapologetic dualist I think
Consciousness is a thing apart I think
experience is a thing apart really
that's a whole other conversation that
we should have at some point but yeah
and so and I love fighting with people
about it I used to make a living
fighting with people like Daniel denn oh
actually his his books right here proof
sure yeah I I I I made I would argue
with him and other people about it for
money and it's great I love it but
anyway so I'm I'm a dieh hard dualist I
believe in experience and Consciousness
as a separate thing I think we need it
in high-tech times in order to identify
who the beneficiary of the technology is
I think if we blend people into the
background we can't identify who we're
do this for anymore so there's a new
pragmatic reason to care about
Consciousness but whatever so that's
that's what I get out of it yeah I
totally recognize someone else can go to
it with a different philosophy and get a
different message no totally even as a
non-dist myself you know one of the
things that has always struck me as
interesting you know this framing of
Thomas Nagel in terms of you know how do
you understand whether something has an
inner world is there something that it's
like to be that entity and of course
used the Bat as his primary example what
is it like to be a bat now if you can go
into a virtual world and really be a bat
and really experience what it is to be a
bat perhaps your Consciousness can shift
in a way and get closer to the
consciousness of a bat you know just as
a concrete example and I think
philosophically those kinds of
experiences could have an unusual impact
to really shift discussion this is my
very favorite stuff about reality really
like this is for me the very best way to
use it the very coolest thing I love
this yeah yeah so uh one hopes that
that's where where this uh will all go
at some point well J we're out of time
it's been a fascinating conversation one
that if you're willing I'd love to have
part two at some point because I feel
like there's so much more to talk about
but thanks so much uh thanks so much for
joining us and uh look best of luck in
pushing the frontiers of all these
fields going forward and it's really
really exciting thank you cool cool cool
really really nice to talk to you great
to see you all right everybody thank you
for joining us that's our conversation
for today again sign up for World
Science Festival newsletter or join our
YouTube channel to be alerted when these
various conversations and programs are
brought forward when they're posted and
also you should know that we are going
to have a nice live event in New York
City toward the end of May here in 2024
so if you find yourself in New York
around then you should certain join our
live programming thanks so much for
joining us I'm Brian Green from New York
World Science Festival see you
[Music]
soon